For this project I’m going to show you how
to make a water balloon slingshot that’ll
give you power and prestige while defending
and dominating your next water fight. This
sling-bow will lob water bombs over 150 feet
away and wreak havoc on friends and family.
Not to mention, it’ll shoot up to 3 balloons
at a time.
Let’s start this project with a trip to
the hardware store for 1/2” PVC tubing
and handful of sprinkler fittings. These adaptors
are all pretty standard, and you should be
able to find them at a home improvement, or
sprinkler supply outlet, near you.
I went ahead and cut the tubing into 1-3/4”,
2”, 5”, and 10” pieces so we can jump
right in and get busy connecting them all
together.
Now just like any PVC project it’s a really good
idea to dry-fit everything together just to
make sure all the pieces are going to fit,
before you glue them together.
And it’s a good idea to practice putting
an angle on the bow forks first, by propping
the handle on a small box, then simply pushing
the prongs down on either side until they
touch the table. This will angle both sides
symmetrically, without the need for any precision instruments.
The basic frame for your sling-bow should
look something like this, and if it does,
then the next step, is to cement it together,
so it can take some abuse.
To make my connections, I’m using a fast
set cement because it’s lightening fast
when it sets, and doesn’t require a primer
to clean the connections first.
However, it’s really important to follow
the directions on the back to make sure your
connections are as strong as possible, because
you don’t want your bow breaking under pressure.
Cement it together one connection at a time
and be prepared to work quickly, because once
two pieces touch, you’ll only have about
5 seconds to get them into place before they
lock up, and won’t move anymore.
That’s why using a box to help set
the angle, can make all the difference in
whether you get them into position with enough
time to spare.
Now you can see I glued all the pieces together
except for the two inside tubes, and that’s important.
We’ll glue these together in a minute, but
for now, make sure to keep them separate.
In the mean-time, let’s take our bow frame
to the next level with a couple cans of spray paint.
Of course I colored mine black and yellow,
but you can paint yours any color you want.
Or even use Duck Tape to make a quick and
easy custom wrap, like we did for the Laser
Blowgun. You’ll see how to make this in
another project video.
Ok, now that we’ve got our custom colors,
we’re ready to add the sling.
I found a 50” workout band in the sporting
goods section of a local super center, and
coincidentally, it’s black and yellow as
well, which matches my color scheme perfectly.
These bands have a handle at either end, which
we won’t actually need. So go ahead and
chop them off with a pair of scissors, but
don’t throw them away just yet. Let’s
salvage the padded foam handles, and repurpose
them for our sling bow instead.
Cut the strap off the handles and carefully
pull the padding off so you’re left with
just the foam exteriors.
Twist them onto the outside of the 1/2”
PVC pipe, and you should find they make a
perfect fit, and stretch the entire length
of the tubes.
Now before we glue the handles back onto the
frame we actually need to roll the ends of
the foam down a little so they’re out of
the way. Both sides should be folded back
so there’s enough space to glue the ends,
without any glue touching the foam.
If there is, then go ahead and apply the cement
to the connections, and twist them together like you did the others.
Do the same thing with all four connections,
and give it about 2 minutes for the cement
to begin curing, then unroll the ends of the
foam so they overlap part of the PVC Tee,
which you can see, gives us a nice handle
grip.
With the padded foam handles in place, the
frame is finished and looking good, so let’s
move on to making the sling next.
We need a way to join the two ends of the
rubber tubing together, and I found a really
effective way to do that is with a disposable
pen.
Take the pen apart and cut two to three inches
off the tube, then carefully use one of the
blades on your scissors to score angled markings
down the sides. Do this as many times as you
can on both ends, making sure the plastic
is scored at about a 45º angle away from the tips.
Now it’s going to take a bit of effort,
but you need to push half of the pen inside
the tubing, so apply some pressure and wiggle
it around, and eventually it’ll slide into place.
Push the other end of the tubing on the same
way until both pieces butt up next to each
other and become one. It should be hard to
tell where they join, and if you pull them
apart as hard as you can, the grooves in the
pen should lock onto the rubber, and prevent
the joint from coming apart.
Alright now that we’ve got an enormous homemade
rubber band, it’s time to make the launching
pouch, and all we’ll need for that, is a
roll of Duck Tape.
Most Duck Tape is 2” wide, and we need 4
strips cut around 18” long. While you’re
here, cut 4 more strips about 14” as well.
Carefully overlap the longer strips just a
bit, and press them together so you can effectively
double the width of the tape. If you do that
with all 4 pieces, you should end up with
a nice large piece of Duck Tape fabric, with
the sticky side facing up.
Now just for convenience, I marked the tape
so you can see where everything will get attached,
and if you center two of the 14” strips
facing down, and press them into place, you
should be left with 4” exposed in the center,
and 5” on the sides.
Carefully wrap the tape around to the backside
and press it smooth, but keep the two black
strips facing upward, because we’ll need
them for attaching this to the tubing next.
Now bring back the big rubber band and stretch
it sideways, so the bands lay exactly on top
of the black strips, and double check that
the pen tube connection is in the center.
Fold one side of the material over the tube,
and press the sticky side down so it adheres
to the inner pad, then smooth the tape until
it’s flat. The other side gets folded over
next, and smoothed down as well the same way.
Alright, the pouch is nearly done, and you
can see how this design let’s it slide freely
up and down the band, making it easily adjustable.
The only thing our launcher needs now, is a handle.
Grab the last two strips of Duck Tape and
fold one of the strips lengthwise into thirds,
then wrap the other piece of tape around it
to make it even stronger.
Now cut 2 slits in the center of the pouch
about 2” from either end, so you can weave
the strap through both of the holes. And when
you pull it flat, it should look like this.
Trim the ends of the strap, so that when you
fold them in toward the middle, they meet
the edge of the handle in the center.
Surprisingly, all it takes to hold them securely
in place, is a 5” strip of tape. So just
lay one overtop, and press it down smooth.
Our launcher is finished and looking good,
so let’s go ahead and attach it to the bow.
Start by lining the ends of the tubing up
with the grooves in the tips of the bow, then
double check that the tubing is symetrical
with the pouch exactly in the center.
Grab one side and stretch the rubber down
as hard as you can, rocking it back and forth
so it slips inside the groove. Then use something
like a 4” cable strap to pinch the tubes
tightly together at the bottom.
Now simply cut the ends off the zip-ties,
making sure they’re smooth, and double check
the rubber is held firmly in the grooves at
the tip. If they are, then you’re done, and ready for action.
I thought it would be fun, to test my Skyblaster
Slingshot, on a recent camping trip with some friends and family.
If you look closely at the pouch when it gets
pulled back, you’ll see it automatically
cups itself, which means it’ll grip onto
balls or water balloons securely, until they’re released.
Just for fun I just loaded up a bucket with
over 100 water balloons ready for blasting,
so we could have some fun and test it out.
The slingshot gets loaded by placing a water
balloon in the pouch while it’s facing upward.
Pull back to lock onto it, then fire when
ready. With only a bit of effort, you’ll
be able to send balloons soaring high into
the sky, and up to 150 feet away.
To get the best leverage, try shooting it
like a bow, and as you practice, your shots
can get incredibly powerful, and impressively
accurate as well.
I tried going for distance, and you can see
this one landed 168 feet away. And I’m confident
that some of you, will get them even farther
than that.
If you want even more power, try laying on
your back and resting your feet on the prongs,
to send your payload even further.
Now depending on which kind of resistance
bands you get, you’ll be able to make sling-bows
any custom color scheme you want. And what’s
really cool is you can make as many as you
want for around $10 bucks each. But check
this out.
I found a box of two, slightly shorter resistance
tubes for the same price as one long one,
which means you can effectively cut the cost
of the rubber in half, and make two slingshots for the price of one.
And just for fun I rigged up a Duck Tape arm
band, that slides down over the frame and
holds the contraption tightly to my arm, which
prevents the end from kicking out on release.
The sling-bow will launch up to 3 balloons
simultaneously. But if you’re thinking of
shooting them at friends or family, there’s
something you need to know first. The balloons
hit hard enough to leave welts. So make sure
anyone being used for target practice is ok
with with it, before you open fire.
And if you’re not in the mood to get anyone
wet, try using your sling-bow to launch one
of the Sky Balls,f we made in another project
video. You’ll see they open up around 40
or 50 feet high in the air, and are guaranteed
outdoor fun for everyone. So keep an eye out
for how to make these Sky Balls, in another
video.
Well now you know how to convert Duck Tape
and resistance rubber, into a powerful water
balloon slingshot. And if you don’t want
to spend money on workout bands, you can always
try modifying a bag of rubber bands instead.
I quickly braided 100 of them into a rubber
rope that makes an impressively effective
and low budget alternative.
Well that’s it for now. If you like this
project perhaps you’ll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com
What’s up guys, thanks for watching my video
to the end, and if you’re ready to get to
work making one of these bad boys for yourself,
I’ve got something that might help.
I just created a set of high quality step-by-step
instructions, for this project that you can
down download instantly, so you’ll have
a hard copy you can reference, while you’re building your slingshot.
I designed this project PDF to be as user
friendly as possible, with high quality pictures,
step by step instructions, as well as some
helpful hints, and fun facts to help you on your way.
They’ll be for sale on my webpage for $10,
so just click here on the screen, or check
the video description for the link on where
to get it. And if you get a copy before the
end of the month, you’ll automatically be
entered to win one of the SkyBlaster Slingshots from this video.
Now to make this an even sweeter deal for
you, my subscribers, I put a private link
in the description to where you can get this
project PDF for only $2.95. That’s 60% off,
and just for you, for watching my videos.
So there you go. See how you’re helping
to support me? And in return I can keep making
more projects and videos for you.
By the way if you download my PDF but don’t
feel like it was worth your money, I’ll
give your money back. How about that?
So you’ve got nothing to lose. Click here
to get yourself a copy, and at least get your name
on the list to win a slingshot.
Thanks again for supporting me and my projects.
I appreciate you, and and I’ll see you in
the next project video. Talk to you then.